damit der hollywood wasser hat vorjahr
murat ernsthaft vom durchbruch okay
gegeben noch nie gemacht haben okay ich
bin gespannt ob halo herzlich willkommen
beim 15 heute machen wir etwas richtig
tolles was richtig geniale was machen
wir nicht von heute und ich gucke ich
könnte es nicht lösen ich glaube das ist
okay wir machen heute die tortilla ist
hört sich mexikanischer keine ahnung
ja und welche zutaten anschaue ist mit
der kartoffel dabei warum ist in beim
kinderkanal dabei hat es ein grund warum
ich immer sagen die kartoffel machen
ich glaube das ist es einfach gut okay
alles klar
so ein richtiger türkei immer mehr
sorgen sagt auf jeden fall machen heute
hat elias und die sanierer kommt gleich
von der schule die sallys auf der
baustelle und die ist bei der oma
deswegen mache ich jetzt was für mich
und für samira und wir sind hier an mich
und das müssen dabei haben ich habe hier
53 gramm kartoffeln die habe ich
übrigens schon gekocht und geschält hier
habe ich hab's olivenöl warum raps
oliven öl weil ich einfach vergessen hat
oder das falsche mitgenommen haben
normalerweise nur olivenöl aber ich
kaufe nur raps oliven ich weiß gar nicht
warum
dann haben wir hier milch ich weiß auch
nicht wie wir müssen wir sind es nicht
dazu 50 50 metern
dann haben hier drei eier politischen
bühne dann brauchen wir peter siegel ich
hatte keine frische petersilie
deswegen habe ich die von der seite
genommen die freedom alles ein als sich
der wahnsinn hier alles eingefroren
wenn es möglich wäre die eltern
einzuführen damit sie lange halten dann
haben wir hier
muskat bei muskat blick die bitte
aufpassen
es ist das ist das kein
gesundheitsschädlich seien wieder zu
viel
okay dann haben wir hier alle rabiater
der sich eine gewürzmischung und zwar
ist da sind da was ist da drin zwiebel
flotten die flocken sind knoblauch
blocken zwiebel oregano genau
genau also ich finde das würzen wir
möchten ja und dann haben wir noch salz
und pfeffer ok jetzt alles ihr merkt
auch dass meine gericht nicht nur
einfach es ist auch sehr sehr günstig
machen so was ist erst als ich mache ich
nehme mir die schönen kartoffeln von
einem fensterbauer richtig schöne
kartoffeln und werde die kartoffeln
einfach in scheiben steigend so die
kartoffel sind noch warm
es ist komisch aus aber das ist alles
gewollt ist rick und zwar passiert das
wenn die kartoffeln noch warm sind dann
kleben sondern der klinge wieder
geschnitten was auch hört auch so zu
guten ganz ja wenn ich mir anschaue dann
mache ich fehler
deswegen ich muss mich konzentrieren
beim kartoffel schneiden ich habe so
lange was anderes zimmer kannst die
panik
ich bin gleich so weit auseinander
geschnitten und was machen sie als
nächstes ich glaube mit von ah ja genau
wohl auch gepasst haben deswegen bist du
auch hier
ich mache das absichtlich um zu gucken
ob du auch bei der sache ist sondern öl
in die pfanne und zwar ist es eine
eisenbahn eine eisenbahn er muss ehrlich
sagen können in jedem haushalt und was
an der eisernen panne so besonders ist
das könnte bei sally auf ihrem kanal
geht einzig technik kanal auf youtube
mit 2 km übrigens gibt es mal ein und
dann kommt auch die videos wie gesagt
das ist ein eisen fall die muss man
langsam erhitzen sonst von weg die sich
immer auf stufe 3 genau gesagt das öl in
der pfanne ich hier auch relativ schnell
jetzt und jetzt haben wir die kartoffeln
und was machen jetzt also ich glaube die
kartoffeln angebraten genau und so sechs
bis acht minuten hast du vorhin gesagt
ja genau hin
gut aufgepasst also dann immer die
kartoffel und warten bis 30 das kann
jetzt vielleicht noch zwei minuten
warum einfach mal die kartoffeln schälen
anbraten in japan schön am boden lang
vorteil
und ich weiß nicht warum ich kann doch
ein schöner boden verteidigt
natürlich mäßig
dies kann jetzt haben wir das alles weg
während die kartoffel schön antraten
mache ich jetzt hier mal wie sagt man
dazu sagen so sehen oder ist die binde
die eier milch macht das sehr gut gut
ausgedrückt gut gelernt von mir genau
die eier milch machen machen wir wenn
wir die eier natürlich nur bio irish
ganz ganz wichtig dann nehmen wir die
milch dazu jetzt waren 50 milliliter
sagt mir drei gefrorene petersilie
da machen wir nicht zu viel riskieren so
schwiegereltern
jetzt haben wir hier noch die gewürze
ist areva arrabiata mal mit rein
wahnsinn oder die ausbildung nicht rein
gemacht habe waren mich endet irgendwann
jamie oliver alles ist total verklebt
wenn jetzt die wenigsten der hand
reinigen die ganze masse und wisse
ausquetschen mache ich aber nicht die
süßen schnee wesen so jetzt freuen wir
uns sehr sagt irgendwas vergessen
du hast das vergessen daran müsste die
muskatnuss salz pfeffer könnte ja und
zwar wie gesagt nicht zuviel muskatnuss
weil das ich glaube es ist muskat uns
auch mit rock oder aphrodisierenden
wurde sowas gar keine ahnung ist schauen
auch kinder zu dreimal drehen fertig
dann immer noch ein bisschen pfeffer
und noch ein bisschen salz ich musste
noch mal um spielen oder ja richtig
beobachtet
ganz einfach ist
das kann schnell da muss man geboren
sein
jawohl die kartoffel schön anbraten
in der eisenbahn als nächstes machen wir
was ich glaube was aber die folgen
gesagt die kartoffeln in die eimer so
genau
also was machen wir jetzt die karte
aufnehmen die eimasse oder wir lassen es
noch ein bisschen anbraten dann wird es
ein richtig tolles röstaromen die
arbeitet gern mit rom anlass gerne mal
alles anbrennen so wahnsinn wir schon
richtig wissen was gerade geschieht nach
kartoffeln ja wahnsinn
schade dass es kein großes fernsehen
gibt so jetzt ein bisschen hoch mit der
temperatur gehen wir schon auf neun
es ist toll an sondern richtig tollen
eisen pfanne
ich denke das reicht mir den rest aromen
jetzt immer die kartoffeln einfach
irgendwie in die masse mit rein und
verwirren wie zu einer homogenen masse
ganz ganz wichtig muss in homogene masse
sein
ich wiederhole noch mal homogen das hat
sich richtig intelligent an
das war schon wahnsinn so was machen wir
jetzt waren alles in die pfanne rein und
ab laufen ja man hätte ist natürlich ist
auch einfach die masse in die pfanne
eingeben können aber das wäre zu einfach
gewesen
wir möchten ja nicht einfache sache
machen möchte sachen machen wo jeder
sich fragt warum macht er das jetzt
deswegen machen wir uns hier ein
wahnsinn
jetzt gehen wir diesen panik deswegen
auch eisenbahnen weil das können ja nur
mit eisenbahnen machen
wir müssen den backofen rein ich sehe
hier drei okay machen den backofen zu
gehen wieder auf dem meller backofen
geben ein immer auf menü machen wir
unter oberhitze gehen auf 170 grad und
drücke war statt
jetzt läuft der backofen ungefähr 15
minuten
ich sollte der backofen ungefähr 15
minuten und dann sie machen schon fertig
das heißt diesmal alles geschafft hat
hat man so okay jetzt will ich kurz die
panne aus dem sack um sack so sieht's
aus wahnsinn oder wahnsinn
alle sind begeistert so sieht so sieht's
jetzt aus und jetzt macht mal ist ein
foto der grund sowohl das erste wache
ist okay nach einer pannen foto jetzt
macht er mario ist pippa marius ich
erste ernsthafte jetzt mal hieß die
pfanne
meinst du dich bei apple habe ich mich
im ballett kleid an manchen überraschen
das ist okay heute kein ballett zeit an
mit schlecht mache das nicht anfassen
das heißt ja so normal es macht jetzt
die coolen bilder wo nachher auf dem
top-level sehen können das heißt ja
panel also navy nagel muss ist hellwach
sein heißt mail daumen
jetzt haben wir ein foto gemacht in der
pfanne und jetzt brauchen wir auch einen
teller und dafür gibt es nach hama trick
dafür habe ich wirklich jahre lang
trainiert im chinesischen bergbau zeigen
dass jetzt einfach dieses ding hier
ernsthaft jetzt das war nicht gut das
war nicht gut was können wir machen das
jetzt so wenn du bist du so was aber
jetzt mal was anders machen das jetzt so
rein so marius
wahnsinnig angelegt sorgt ein foto
schießen das ist freilich das schafft
auch nicht jeder
[Musik]
hier haben wir jetzt so lange stehen
bleiben
die bestehende deko bleibt stehen passt
laufen hier so sieht es aus fertig wenn
ein bisschen mehr öl in die pfanne rein
macht dann dann bleibt es auch jemanden
antreten
merkt euch immer eins aus niederlagen
lernt man nicht aus erfolgen dh ein
bisschen was besser auch eine heiße bahn
ist sehr sehr gefährlich
deswegen lassen wir das mal probieren
und fragen nach seiner ehrlichen mein
lieber marius ich bin nicht probieren
mal ehrlich hinzuschauen wenn sie
zusammen nachmachen und schmeckt möchten
versuchen sie sich wahrscheinlich oder
nicht und da ihr zug ja und seine
zukunft kinder wahrscheinlich auch aber
wenn ich ehrlich sein
das schmeckt so ein bisschen wie solon
black mit kartoffeln das ist ein omelett
kartoffeln k
das arrabiata gewürz macht sehr
besonders danke schön war das ist sehr
nett von dir ausgerufen also es schmeckt
ja schon ehrliche meinung welt ist kann
ich immer sein dass immer was machen wie
schmeckt euch und die zuschauer denken
da schmeckt also tatsächlich etwas
verbessern müssen was verbessern
vielleicht ein bisschen mehr würze
übertreibt nicht okay aber sonst topf
ist auch okay dann brauche ich auch mal
nach denen eine gabel
ja ich bin ich noch und du bist gesund
okay
vor schmid mit kartoffel ein bisschen
salz noch rein aber ist geschmackssache
mir gesagt schnell gemacht wenn ihr wer
ein bisschen übung drin habt dann macht
es wirklich wahrscheinlich sieben oder
acht minuten habt es geschafft oder mit
ein bisschen vorlaufzeit natürlich
kartoffeln sind wichtig aber toller
erfolg bin macht mir noch immer auf die
häuser verläuft ja immer auf die heiße
pfanne man aufpassen hat mich mordsmäßig
spaß gemacht mit der hält natürlich
nicht ich könnte es nicht ich finde es
wirklich nicht verkraften
ich liebe euch euer morath macht sinn
macht es besser
[Musik]